quiero hacer una pequeña aclaración del
vídeo anterior para pensar que es
realmente la fricción cuando el bloque
se está moviendo y en el último vídeo
empezamos con con un bloque que era
estacionario y sabíamos que la
componente paralela a la superficie del
plano de la fuerza de gravedad eran 49
newtons y si nuestro bloque está
estacionario quiere decir que hay una
fuerza de fricción que contrarresta la
fuerza en la dirección paralela verdad y
esa fuerza de fricción tiene la misma
magnitud y que es de 49 newtons pero por
supuesto hacia arriba de la rampa ahora
si subimos un poco la fuerza que
ejercemos sobre este digamos que a lo
mejor alguien aquí desde este lado está
empujando poco a poco entonces va a
llegar un momento en donde este bloque
va a acceder y hasta a moverse y eso
dijimos que ocurría cuando empujábamos
un newton si empujamos tantito - no se
iba a mover por ejemplo si nosotros
empujamos 49 newtons
o más bien si teníamos la fuerza en la
dirección paralela de la fuerza de
gravedad en dirección paralela a la
superficie y además empujamos digamos
medio newton digamos punto 5 newtons y
entonces no se iba a mover pero lo que
quiero aclarar aquí es que en ese caso
la fuerza de fricción no es la misma
verdad si queremos que este bloque se
mantenga estacionario y yo empujó con
medio newton digamos si le aplico medio
newton sabemos que este no se va a mover
pero entonces la fuerza de fricción
tiene que ser exactamente igual a la
resultante que en este caso serían 49
newtons y medio newton por ejemplo si yo
aplicara una fuerza neta hacia abajo de
la rampa de 49.99 99 newtons entonces la
fricción va a ser de la misma y va a
tener la misma cantidad ok entonces la
fuerza de fricción no es constante si no
se neutraliza hasta el momento en el que
llegamos a 50 minutos dijimos que en 50
minutos entonces
y el nuestro bloque empieza a ceder al
movimiento ok entonces aquí hay nuestra
fuerza de fricción cambia según lo que
estemos aplicando muy bien ahora
pensemos en otro escenario ahora vamos a
pensar y de hecho déjenme hacer un
dibujo nuevo para trabajar este ejemplo
digamos que aquí mismo tenemos nuestra
rampa aunque ella y está en nuestra
rampa y digamos que tenemos el mismo
bloque muy bien tenemos nuestro mismo
bloque ok tenemos el mismo ángulo verdad
vamos a considerar el mismo ángulo vamos
a considerar de hecho exactamente igual
que tenemos
que tenemos este bloque de de 10
kilogramos de masa y por lo tanto tiene
una fuerza de gravedad que se descompone
en dos una que va en dirección
perpendicular a la superficie déjeme
ponerla un poco mejor ahí lo tienen esta
fuerza perpendicular a la superficie que
era de 49 raíz de 3 newtons y teníamos
una fuerza que va en dirección paralela
aunque esta es la componente paralela de
la fuerza de gravedad que desde 49
newtons entonces como este cuerpo se
encuentra sobre una superficie entonces
hay una fuerza normal hay una fuerza
normal que le imprime la superficie en
dirección perpendicular pero hacia
arriba verdad
digamos más o menos ahí lo tienen y está
se neutraliza con la componente
perpendicular de la gravedad porque así
este cuerpo ya no va a acelerar hacia
adentro del de la rampa entonces este
tiene 49 raíz de 3 minutos y vamos a
suponer que vamos a hacer una suposición
extra en este caso voy a no voy a
suponer que que el que la caja o este
bloque está en un equilibrio que es
estacionario sino lo que voy a hacer o
la diferencia al caso anterior vamos a
hacer que este cuerpo se mantenga con
una velocidad constante ok entonces
vamos a provocar que este cuerpo vamos a
pensar que el cuerpo tiene una velocidad
constante muy bien y sólo para asentar
alguna idea vamos a suponer que tiene
una velocidad de 5 metros por segundo
metros por segundo hacia abajo
hacia abajo ok y por supuesto no estamos
pensando hacia abajo de la rampa verdad
de la rampa y entonces recordemos que
como la velocidad es un vector hay que
decir exactamente en qué dirección va
entonces uno podría pensar que como se
está moviendo entonces debe haber alguna
fuerza neta que está actuando sobre este
bloque pero tenemos que tener mucho
cuidado que es lo que hay que recordar
que es lo que dice la primera ley de
newton y la primera ley de newton nos
dice que si un cuerpo está o más bien si
si aplicamos una fuerza o bueno en
términos más más concretos un cuerpo
mantiene su estado de equilibrio o el
movimiento rectilíneo uniforme a menos
de que una fuerza externa se le imprima
verdad entonces si aquí mantenemos una
velocidad constante no está acelerando
quiere decir que las fuerzas todas se
cancelan verdad entonces aquí está
diciendo que no está acelerando y por lo
tanto no hay una
fuerza neta que se le está imprimiendo a
este cuerpo quiere decir entonces que la
fuerza de la está hay una fuerza que
contrarresta la fuerza o la componente
paralela a la fuerza de gravedad verdad
entonces debe haber una fuerza que lo
contrarreste y este es de 49 newtons y
que va en dirección también paralela a
la superficie pero hacia arriba de la
rampa verdad y por supuesto esta fuerza
que estás viendo aquí ya puedes ir
adivinando que es la fuerza de fricción
muy bien entonces la diferencia con el
caso anterior es que la fricción en este
caso mantiene la velocidad constante y
está digamos anulando la componente
paralela de la fuerza de gravedad verdad
que eran de 49 newtons entonces lo
interesante ahora en este ejemplo será
lo siguiente vamos a tratar de calcular
un coeficiente en el caso anterior
habíamos encontrado un coeficiente de
fricción estática y que lo denota vamos
con la letra griega muy verdad y le
poníamos un subíndice ed
ahora en este caso en este vídeo vamos a
hacer un coeficiente distinto en este
vídeo vamos a tratar el que vamos a
calcular el coeficiente de fricción
dinámica o cinética vamos a llamarlo
coeficiente de fricción cinética
y
como les decía esta es la letra griega
muy le ponemos un subíndice de cinético
también se le conoce como coeficiente de
fricción dinámica pero bueno vamos a
dejarlo de esta forma ok entonces esto
es igual vamos a definirlo como el
cociente entre la magnitud de la fuerza
de fricción para en el caso en que
nuestra caja se mantiene a velocidad
constante dividido entre la magnitud
entre la magnitud de la fuerza normal
muy bien que era justamente 49 raíz de 3
newtons entonces lo que en otro vídeo
vamos a tratar cuál es la gran
diferencia entre o como como estos dos
coeficientes el coeficiente de fricción
cinética y el coeficiente de fricción
estática ok
como son como es que pueden llegar a ser
distintos en muchas ocasiones son muy
similares verdad pero en este caso este
coeficiente de fricción cinética es
válido para muchas parejas digamos de de
objetos en este caso
a nuestra caja en nuestra rampa eso es
válido para muchas parejas que son del
mismo material y te puede ayudar a
predecir cómo sería el movimiento por
ejemplo si tomáramos otros ángulos de
inclinación o algunas otras fuerzas de
gravedad o digamos si estamos en algún
otro planeta verdad entonces para este
caso concreto el coeficiente de fricción
cinética va a ser igual a él aquí la
fuerza de fricción es de 49 newtons muy
bien dividido entre la fuerza normal que
es cups vamos a ponerlo en azul es 49
raíz de 3 newtons entonces si hacemos
estas cuentas rápidos se cancelan los 49
los minutos también se cancelan y nos
queda 1 sobre la raíz de 3 y éste no
tiene unidades justamente porque estamos
cancelando los newton simplemente es un
coeficiente verdad entonces vamos a ver
en digamos en decimales cuánto es eso 1
entre raíz de 3 entonces sería 1
dividido en
la raíz cuadrada de 3 y eso es un eso es
0.50 y 77 vamos a redondear lo como 0.58
entonces esto será 0.58 entonces como
puedes ver es similar al
en similar al caso anterior pero es más
chiquito y de hecho esto no es un
resultado así este extraño y novedoso en
general uno puede observar que el
coeficiente de fricción estática el
perdón el coeficiente de fricción
cinética es menor o igual que el
coeficiente de fricción estática ok el
coeficiente de fricción cinética es
menor o igual que el de estática y de en
otro vídeo vamos a tratar de teorizar
esto pero una vez no sé por qué bueno
así se pero vamos a tratar de teorizar
lo en otro vídeo pero una vez que algo
se empieza a mover por alguna razón que
vamos a discutir después la fricción es
menos potente que cuando algo es
estacionario aunque entonces vamos a
pensar un poco más a detalle sobre esto
en el siguiente vídeo